los ciudadanos estadounidenses se salen
a votar en las elecciones legislativas
de medio término para esta jornada la
impopularidad del presidente Joe biden
está ayudando a impulsar la opinión de
que los republicanos obtendrían el
control de la cámara de representantes
de Estados Unidos y posiblemente también
del senado del país Este martes el
control de incluso una cámara del
Congreso les daría a los republicanos el
poder de detener la agenda legislativa
del mandatario que asumió en 2021 en
medio de la pandemia de Kobe 19 y que ha
tenido que asumir a sí mismo las
cicatrices económicas de esta crisis
sanitaria mundial incluida la inflación
su índice de aprobación no llegó al 36%
en mayo y en junio con ese panorama se
renuevan un tercio del senado y las
totalidad de la cámara además de algunas
gobernaciones la conversación sobre este
tema es con Felipe cala Él es director
de incidencia para América Latina y el
Caribe de Open society foundations
Felipe gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros se que los republicanos ganen
el control al menos de la cámara de
representantes e incluso eventualmente
del senado cómo sería en ese caso el
escenario de gobernabilidad de Paraguay
Ángela Buenos días y muchas gracias por
la invitación Bueno como como señalas tú
hoy hoy se decide el control por el
congreso tanto la totalidad de la cámara
de representantes como 35 sillas del
senado en caso en que los republicanos
tomen el control de las dos cámaras
bueno el escenario se complicaría
bastante para el presidente
Joe byden como como sabes el
y la mayoría en el congreso Define que
se discute que se vota y en qué se gasta
Y aunque el presidente con un margen de
maniobra mínimo Ha logrado pasar algunos
algunas piezas de legislación
significativas hacia adelante las cosas
se complicarían bastante pero creo que
también algo bien importante para
Resaltar pues son las 36 carreras
por por las gobernaciones de distintos
estados que también podrían definir el
el panorama para las elecciones
presidenciales en dos años eso también
complicaría bastante la agenda demócrata
hacia futuro Bueno hablemos de un tema
histórico Y es que la oposición
normalmente vence en las elecciones de
medio mandato porque este fenómeno Cómo
afecta el equilibrio de poder en un país
tan diverso y tan grande como Estados
Unidos
si es ha sido esa ha sido la tendencia
histórica en en Estados Unidos
y claramente hoy Parece que no va a ser
la excepción las las encuestas le dan el
control de la cámara de representantes a
los republicanos Y últimamente hemos
visto una tendencia en las encuestas
sobre el senado en esa misma en esa
misma dirección
es
bastante posible
y en términos del equilibrio de poderes
Ángela Creo que creo que pues es
simplemente el funcionamiento de una de
una democracia pero pero definitivamente
en estas elecciones los republicanos
en ciertos estados
han impulsado a agendas para para
restringir el voto para limitar el voto
a distancia para lograr que no se
cuenten votos que habían sido enviados
por correo como es el caso de
Pensilvania lo cual ha ocasionado una
mediocrisis Pues esta mañana mañana y
ayer en en Filadelfia y en otras
ciudades de del Estado entonces pues
sean se han llevado a cabo digamos
estrategias y tácticas bastante dudosas
que han restringido el voto en cierta
medida y que claramente no contribuya en
términos de equilibrio de equilibrio de
poderes Pero bueno el congreso estará
estará a ahí para para ejercer sus
funciones de control y pues eso como
decíamos le complicaron para un poco la
vida al presidente yobai tenía la
administración demócrata muy bien Felipe
vamos a hablar de los temas que son
decisivos para los votantes Uno de ellos
es de los precios que además ha afectado
mucho la popularidad de Joe biden y
quisiera que así hiciéramos una balanza
de ese tema Como por ejemplo una de las
grandes campañas demócratas en estas
elecciones y es el aborto la defensa del
aborto que fue anulado como derecho
nacional con el fallo robby como entra
ahí por ejemplo el voto de las mujeres
bueno por un lado Ángela los temas que
le están preocupando
están un poco
lejos de los temas que han impulsado los
demócratas en estas en estas elecciones
de medio término los precios
obviamente han subido y la inflación a
pesar de esfuerzos muy concretos de esta
administración no ha bajado
lo no ha bajado lo que ellos habrían
esperado que bajara y se ha mantenido
alrededor del 8%, eso ha sido el tema y
la preocupación central para los para
los votantes
demócratas y República
a lo largo y ancho del país
incluso para las mujeres incluso para
las mujeres creo que los los demócratas
sobre estimaron el peso que hubiera
podido tener el tema del aborto todo de
la decisión de la Corte Suprema de
rescindir El fallo de Robert
Y aunque activo en cierta medida
a los demócratas durante el verano sobre
todo en Estados
con tendencia republicana donde donde
este derecho
está más en en contienda y y está más en
peligro
la verdad con la inflación persistente
los los votantes no le han dado el peso
que que los demócratas
esperaban que le que les fuera dar al
que le fueran a dar al tema del del
aborto hay una hay una desconexión creo
yo
los votantes
están viendo los temas económicos están
viendo los temas de Crimen y seguridad
están viendo el tema migratorio como
como las tres prioridades claves de la
de la de la elección y sin embargo la
calificación de los demócratas en el
manejo de esos temas no es
les dan le dan una calificación alta en
los temas de derechos sexuales
productivos en los temas de cambio
climático y otros temas de políticas
social Pero lamentablemente Eso no eso
no son los los temas que están en el del
votante norteamericano hoy